apparently I love that show me the dream
um honestly if a guy walked up to me
holding a baby it would be game over I
mean he wouldn't even have to say
anything I'd be like okay you can just
breed me now
you do just needs to roll up with a kid
and you're like all right I will take
you away from your wife and I'm now
raising that okay in this hypothetical
situation hopefully the child is both
not a duck as a mother-in-law
not you know he's not married you know
that's the goal you'd prefer a single
dad over a single guy
I don't know if I would necessarily
prefer it but I would absolutely be a
stepmother I have a lot of love to give
and I love kids and I don't think I
would have any issue in both respecting
the mother and their co-parenting
relationship but also taking a child
who's not mine biologically and making
it feel as though it is mine you tell me
what you guys think okay
question to the audience question for
the for the panel
I feel like women are way more likely to
be with a dude that already has kids
then a man is willing to be with a girl
with kids example I know plenty of girls
here in Miami that are like stepmom to
the dude with the kids
I was talking to a girl for a while she
had kids and I was like what we'll see
we'll see one time like she like
canceled on a date because the kid got
sick I'm like I'm out like this is this
is so absurd I'm now like my life is now
being run by Timmy over here who [ __ ]
has a cold I'm like I'm not this is so
something I'm not doing and I'm like
I've been I just jump ship
amazing girl gorgeous girl and like
despite all the accolades as a woman I
was like yeah I can't raise someone
else's kids or I can't have my schedule
revolve around some other dude's kids
just not for me but how willing are you
guys as as women to raise another dude's
kids is that something you'd be open to
I have the right guy I have dated a guy
pretty seriously he had two kids from a
previous marriage and I liked the fact
that I got to see how he was as a father
before you know having kids with him but
it just kind of came down to the fact of
I want my own kids one day as well and
having a blended family for you know us
as a couple it was just something that
wasn't in the card so it just ended up
not working out but I'm totally open to
dating a man with kids as long as he's
open to having more kids in the future
because that's something that I want uh
so there was a prerequisite like I'm
down to raise your kids but I want my
own that's like the show we were on last
week it was the couple they each had two
kids they kind of had a Brady Bunch
thing going on totally okay with that if
you have your own kids as a dude and the
girls that are own kids that's a little
bit easier rather than like we did a we
did an episode on the pbd podcast this
dude out here Kyle Kolinski shout out to
you I think you're very smart no doubt
you know you're you're you know your
stuff in politics this guy is marrying a
woman who is
five to ten years older and has three
kids I'm sorry I'm putting his business
out there but it's already out there
this is not a secret
homie is gonna go from zero kids to
three kids the second he says I do that
is very tough to do as a dude it's a lot
of kids
she's in her early 40s he's in his early
30s and he's going to be raising
someone else's kids now I will say in
case this thing gets chopped up and sent
to him they have a lot in common they
both work in politics they're both
liberals they do like shows together so
like there is that component respect you
guys find love to where you find it but
raising someone else's kids and they're
like 10 12 and 15. she said she should
write a dating advice book on how the
hell she pulled that off there's a lot
of girls that want to know wow yeah
anyway that's I'm going off the deep end
here would you ever date a dude that
already has kids
um I don't want to say never because I
think for the right guy most girls would
probably right yeah
um it's really not my preference I just
think you know I grew up with two
parents in the home all the same parents
I mean obviously minus the ones that
were adopted but
um I just thought that was easier that
way so that would definitely be my
preference so you're open to it
um I would say I'm not open to it
however I I'm not going to cap and say
that if the right guy came along I
wouldn't make it it's not open to it
it's not ideal but you're not closed off
to it yeah like I'd probably make an
exception for the right guy that's what
girls do by the way they make exceptions
for exceptional men
nugget that was a good one oh my reading
ain't doing good today but my talking's
doing all right Jamie
yes okay have you ever dated a dude with
kids and would you be willing to do it
again yes uh I did a man
I my dad adopted me and so my mom was a
single mom and she came out of an
abusive relationship and he took me in
as his own and they even got my birth
certificate changed so I wouldn't know
he's like this will be my kid
um and I think growing up
that always meant a lot to me like to
adopt because someone like took me in um
but when I dated him like I was there
doing all the family stuff talking with
the baby mama like having conversations
talking with the baby mama yeah there
was time to underscore how difficult
that is also do you ever have to deal
with the baby mama yeah there was
definitely overlap and you know holiday
is Christmas and things that was
something to keep in mind too it's it
doesn't say I would do the kid I take
another person's kid like and be a
stepmom any day
be a co-parent with a baby mama that's a
different story because that man ended
up trying to like cheat on me with said
baby Mama no he tried to get back with
the baby mama I was like babysitting his
child putting him into bed reading him
stories like while he was on a a trip
with his brother and uh that is the
shadiest thing I've ever heard here you
are dating a dude okay
he has a kid a two-year-old
you're in the house rearing the child
taking care of the child lo and behold
low-key the dad is on some business trip
vacation with his boys meanwhile banging
his ex-wife baby mama behind your back
yeah that's [ __ ] up that's low yeah I
it basically like sold me a dream like
we're gonna get married have kids I like
I wanted he wanted somebody who was like
nurturing and good with kids so when he
introduced me to his son that was kind
of like what made us a little bit more
serious his mother would buy me gifts
because she was like you're so good with
his children thank you we were worried
based on who like the mom is and they
all painted this dream that this girl
was kind of crazy and they needed that
like stability and I was like I'll do
that and so while he was telling me one
thing about her he was like dming her
and trying to [ __ ] and wow yeah but I
would say that words versus actions like
we were talking about him exactly that
still wouldn't make me not do it again
you would do it again despite that
because for me it's like the kids thing
if he's a good man and he's doing that
like I'm not gonna make it like I'm not
gonna get salty based on a past
experience of it so a dude here's what
I'm learning here gentlemen
go rent a kid go rent a kid I'll tell
you a story
last week at the Soho House in Miami my
brother-in-law and my sister were saying
hey can you uh watch Rory my nephew I
was like yeah I'm at the sew house I'm
at the beach they're like just take him
with you when I tell you here I am at
the beach okay and there's people around
and I start throwing the football with
little Rory
can I play I'm like Rory just throw it
over there by accident
girls are like oh is that your son he's
so cute I'm like nephew how you doing
right she's like oh
chick magnet yeah what's a better chick
magnet a puppy or a kid a kid a kid a
kid go rent a kid starting a business
shout out to my nephew Rory if you're
watching this I love you buddy every
weekend watching this yes he's like four
he's ten oh okay anyway keep doing you
kid okay so I'm learning this it is way
more attractive for a man to have a kid
and way more compelling for a woman to
be like yeah I'd co-sign on that for a
man to try to date like a woman with
kids like I've seen like women like I'll
give you one quick story airport I'm
flying back
uh wherever I was I think from Madrid
and
hot ass chick in the airport I mean just
by herself like buying a bagel I'm like
I think I'm a little hungry cream cheese
for you next thing you know I'm like in
line there I am not being creepy at all
I'm just generally looking to buy a
bagel
and but I'm like scoping this chick like
who's she with who she traveling with
right next thing you know the kid comes
up mommy I'm like I'm out I'm out who's
this kid like
her nephew
she's like please
turn on for a dude to see a chick with
kids but it is a turn off why is it not
a turn-on because you're not trying to
raise some other dude's kids it's
because historically like men had to
ensure paternity so they're biologically
predispositioned to be repulsed by other
people's children because they didn't
want their resources to be passed to a
kid that wasn't theirs where us if a guy
has a kid that shows us that he could
take care of us because other women
selected him this is why we bring Pearl
here he's giving you facts not feelings
Jamie oh I know she just hurt your
feelings no no she
but uh I think that wow that may be true
for majority of men there are definitely
men out there who have like an aspect of
just wanting to be a dad and I know a
lot of men who they're like they have
the same feeling of like they like the
girl a lot and they're like you know
what let's do this and have a family
together so I think if you have a kid
you should be looking for men who also
display those yeah but those are men
that don't have options the guys that
can choose pick women without kids the
same way like if we can tell you the
same way
the same way that you guys can choose
you you pick men that are rich yeah my
dad was a Millionaire on one of the
biggest construction companies in Boston
did The Big Dig the Newbury Street
Apartments met my mom crazy woman and he
must have loved her because she was
crazy and she had me and they had two
kids of their own like I think he had
all the options he was a player he was
attractive he had all all of those like
high value characteristics a family
um and I mean he still chose to do it
happens Sierra exists right but the
exceptions don't make the rule and like
to ignore the exceptions is to ignore
the possibility for the people out there
watching right but that goes back to
selling women a dream
and you're gonna you're gonna tell the
average woman that this is what's gonna
happen that millionaire men are gonna
check for her that's just not going to
happen for the average women who do have
children or single moms here are the
characteristics you should look for in a
man if you're looking for a partner
yeah let me just weigh in on this by the
way she hit the nail on the head because
there's rules and exceptions I get it
because so for every general rule you
can be like I know a guy and one time I
met a girl but to shut down any option
of like the acceptance calling in an
exception instead of seeing that it's
actually very common but here's where I
was going with this because you use the
exact word that I was going to use she
used the word options men with options
which we're going to get into men with
options that can pick let's get real
here the type of man that you would want
to date whoever that is like think of
the guy in your mind that you want to
date just go there for a second whoever
that is Rich successful good looking
this family oriented has kids whatever
maybe someone else's kids whatever
that dude has options yeah and the
reason that you like him is because he's
become that man that has options okay so
you you're absolutely right you have the
as a high value man high status man
whatever you have earned the right to
have options and you should explore
those options now you have the option to
get with any girl you want or you have
the option to wife up the chick with two
kids that's your option most guys with
options aren't going to do that though
and that's kind of what you're saying
most of you would want like your brother
or your son to marry a woman with kids
over one that doesn't
maybe if you have a 22 year old 22 year
old brother yeah he has two choices a
girl with two kids and a girl with no
kids
I think it really depends on the woman
like all things equal just the kids just
the kids yeah I wouldn't give a [ __ ]
well first my brother broke as [ __ ] and
I'd be like you shouldn't even have a
girlfriend
[Laughter]
anyway but if he was
he was and there were kids and like I
don't know I want a big family and me my
brother and my sister are kind of
creating that like we are our family
unit unit and so I would accept them and
I know he would love I mean I didn't say
except I said prefer
like why would you want him to sign up
for more problems he has to pay for
those kids he has to deal with the baby
mother or the what is it the baby father
why are reviewing children as problems
because that's how men view it well
that's [ __ ] up headaches it's not
cause I think many view that as a
headache are headaches no no no
your own kids are still a headache and
they are problems but at the net the net
reality is they're worth it like I ask
all my friends this I'm like because I'm
the single guy the single crew and doing
Miami they're like bro take me with you
one of these days take me with you like
I'm like what's up you're married with
kids don't you love your kids love my
kids so much work you have no idea so
now you're taking that dude and you're
like yeah all those problems those
headaches that you you like you choose
to have
now it's not even your kids now it's
like oh God just I'm out and that's kind
of what you're saying if you choose
those kids are they not then your kids
uh to an extent you have to consider
when people
um they blend families together you're
not just blending the kids and like
you're raising the kids like the kids
come from a household that's raised from
a different standard like I come from a
blended family so I understand like the
relationships between the my sisters
that I grew up with versus the Blended
side of my siblings it's very different
it's a different Dynamic we grow kind of
differently we have the same parents
essentially but at the end of the day
like you're almost like fighting with
another household Dynamic when you have
a blended family and that in itself is
the difficult part I don't think kids
are really like difficult like kids
don't really know what they want they're
kind of everywhere they're a mess but we
already know that I think what you're
arguing with is the actual significant
other raising those kids that is where
the real hudit comes in and Ice feel
like at the end of the day if someone
could avoid TR you know avoid that part
of a headache you essentially would
avoid it you you know but everybody's
different it depends what you're looking
for there's some men who don't want to
have their own kids and they're okay
having other people's kids and they're
out there but ideally it's not really
but they're like I'm doing a man with
kids like you know they're unicorns men
that prefer it are unicorns unicorns you
want the episodes
looking for widowed men or women if we
want people with kids we're looking for
widows is that what I'm here
I would maybe say like it's I think it's
very rare to find like people who have
Blended families and like like you have
a relationship with a baby mama is like
to me because a lot of the times when a
man leaves a woman with that they had a
kid with the baby mom is kind of sour
because she was just she left her she
definitely the other part that we don't
really talk about is that men have no
rights to the kids like even if they've
raised them for most of their life so I
have a co-host his name's Sarah and we
we host a show together on Tuesdays and
he raised someone else's kid for 10
years and then she cheated and left and
he had no rights to this kid that's
heartbreaking and that's the risk that
men are signing up for and the other
thing like I always ask women like would
you be okay with a stepfather
disciplining your kid even if you
disagreed with it a lot of times it's no
because that's not their kid women will
weaponize that and be like that's not
your kid that's my kid it's going to go
that way so when it goes back to your
brother why would you have him sign up
for those potential problems when he
could just say you know what no kids
over there that's just easier and I
honestly I would say the same thing to
my sister why would you pick a guy with
kids when you could pick a guy with no
kids let me let me let me finalize this
and we'll move on there's things that
are ideal and then there's things that
you'll deal with okay ideally you just
meet a girl who's great amazing you have
kids together that's ideal
but you'll deal with the fact that you
meet an amazing girl and that you like
her kids and you'll help raise the kids
you'll deal with it but it's not ideal
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible